all right let's talk about rewiring our
brains because the internet and
Technology and phones it is actually
doing it to us let's look at eight ways
that technology is rewiring our brains
we now dream in color which we did not
do a long time ago we're gonna get to
that one in a little bit we experience
FOMO do you guys know what FOMO is you
two hipsters fear of missing out that's
right phantom vibration syndrome which I
think we've all had in our pocket right
now we can't sleep that's a big one our
memory and attention span aren't that
great I really want to talk about that
one we have better visual skills we have
poor impulse control we create more so
these aren't all terrible some of these
are actually good if we have better
visual skills and we're creating more
and connecting with people in different
ways so let's just look at a couple of
these so the the dreaming and color one
I thought was really interesting a 2008
study found out that adults who grew up
in houses with black-and-white TVs were
more likely to dream in black and white
so that's sort of like the first version
of this where somehow technology was
changing what's going on in our brain
doesn't that seem it seems kind of crazy
actually and then I don't even know what
people were dreaming about before they
grew up in a black and white television
where they're dreaming at all like we're
cavemen dreaming and all I mean who
knows I just that seems crazy let me
color no I I mean I don't know that one
seems absolutely crazy to me i I can't
remember any my dreams in the first
place I actually I'm a bit of a dreamer
and it's always in color and I remember
them even if you watched I Love Lucy
they still do a guy they're sometimes
crazy sometimes weird yeah I've always
been a dreamer I have friends who say
they never dream but it there were
studies everyone dreams you just
everyone doesn't remember yeah yeah I
know I don't I always grew up I grew up
in house I'm gonna color TV so that's
probably why I am a color dream - you're
exactly so alright so speaking of dreams
so the that we can't sleep I thought
this was kind of interesting so neuro
scientists suspect that all the lights
from your iPad and your iPhone and
everything else is actually like
scrambling your brain right before you
go to sleep so you can't sleep do you
I suffer from this at all because I
literally just bought blackout curtains
from my bathroom yeah that reason
because the light it it does really like
keep you some level of awake or when you
do kind of wake up to turn over the
light hits your eyes and it makes it
harder for you to go back to sleep but
now the blackout curtains help a lot
shut down do you guys do the shutdown
I've really been trying like an hour
before I go to bed to stop looking at
Twitter really stop so that my brain has
a second just that slowly trying to do 2
which is that like previously into the
last like two weeks I'm terrible at it
but the last thing that I do is look at
my phone and the first thing I do when I
wake up is look at my phone and it's
just it's terrible that does send me
into some not able to sleep kind of
world a terrible because I'm and that
and it sort of I think goes into the
FOMO part which is that I'm always
thinking you know what happened did I
miss something what's going on and I
just can't I can't get to see so I'm
trying to shut that whole thing off yeah
so we'll do one more bad one and then
and then some of the good ones so the
attention span thing I think is the big
one I'm finding this with everybody yeah
people's attention span is completely
shot you can be having a conversation
with someone right face to face like
this and then without a beat they'll
start looking at their phone right in
front of you and as and then the
conversation continues but then they're
answering slower we're all doing it
we're looking this way what you know and
I'm guilty myself is that to me this is
the biggest one of this whole thing that
we're brains are being split into two
worlds the online world and the offline
like I'm usually like answering emails
from work or someone has texted me that
once an immediate response and I'm like
okay I can wait or I can just do this
right now really quick while they're
talking and still listening instantly
and go back to the conversation yeah
like you heard like 80% of what they
said and it's it's a bad habit but we
all do it because we're all our minds
are in all these different places at one
time we're at work or with our friend
we're with this waiting for this to hear
back from something we might want to do
and like all this stuff is happening and
you're just so like why could that
possibly be good because I think the
counter-argument is that because we have
all this stuff that actually we're
starting to be able to multitask in
newer ways and that maybe the technology
will remember things for
so that your brain will be able to use
it you know you'll use that processing
power in your brain for other stuff so
is that I think it would be great if we
were able to improve our multitasking
but I don't think that that's really
possible I mean for me it's like I think
it's strange that when you get a text it
it goes in front of the line of the
person that you're talking to right it's
like when you're at you know when you're
at the deli and you're ordering
something and somebody calls and orders
something on the phone and they go first
and you're like amen how do they go
first right because they call but the
same thing happens now with your phones
all the time trying to send and I just
think guys are really bad in particular
at multitasking you've just never been
able to hear two conversations at the
same time or do two things at the same
time so I hope that it makes us better
but I doubt it yeah all right well we'll
give you one potentially positive one
here that we have better visual skills
the study found out that first-person
shooter games like Halo call a duty I
know Trayvon's a big video game guy that
they actually boost decision-making
skills this was always my argument when
I was playing video games as a kid my
dad would be like get outside of my hand
coordination it's so good do you think
there's some legitimacy to that argument
that maybe through playing video games
and all this digital stuff that maybe we
are doing something that's that's good
at their love Call of Duty I also think
there's truth of that because I was in
college we actually had this video game
that someone developed to make you a
better player hand-eye coordination
timing and decision-making and it was
just a game it was like you were
shooting these little things and having
to time all this stuff and it was
supposed to improve the way you saw the
court the timing you you took with
passing or shooting and decision-making
so apparently there's some truth to it
even though you could actually go
outside and pass and shoot sure do all
that stuff to if you were really old
school all right final thought on this
what about all these people that are
going off the grid do you guys envy them
at all I actually have someone fairly
close to me that is off the grid
legitimately off the grid and I sort of
have this real admiration for it I say
that with all due irony knowing how much
I tweet and do a YouTube show and all
that stuff I'm so jealous of it it's
like a dream of mine to be able to
totally show if somebody was talking
about this theory that they had where
they say it's something called like
using the internet dressed while you're
dressed it's this whole idea that you
know why do you use the your phone or
anything when you're
in bed or well you're you know in your
pajamas you should only use the phone
when you're dressed for work so I like
that theory but I would love to go off
the grid in telling if one of us could
do it it's definitely like you could
take this sweater with you yeah yeah it
might be fine idea for two because I
have a job that requires me beyond the
grave all the time right so will you
switch your job your job becomes like
collecting firewood then your mountain
man exactly throw it about in the church
do you admire these people at all do you
think they're some pride I try to do
like okay I'm gonna go like an hour
without it's baby steps but it's really
hard because everyone's always trying to
contact you for something but don't you
think that you set that up yourself I
mean isn't that a self-imposed sort of
thing however you make yourself
available people will try to get in
right so if you set up those boundaries
maybe I mean I do sometimes depending on
what I'm doing will ignore it until I
have time to get back to it but I'm all
like emails from my agents and people
who are saying hey we got this thing for
you we need to know like right now and
yeah and so those are the things even
though they don't happen enough for me
to be that paranoid they happen enough
that where it's like did I miss anything
because they're having times where I
miss stuff because I didn't respond to
the email in 20 minutes and so I'm like
I got this feeling of like every 20
minutes I got to see what my emails
doing I guess so you just wrapped it all
up for us because you have the fear of
missing out of things that haven't even
happened and that's why you're looking
at your phone but those things bring me
money actual wrap up a building